- You know, products
can sometimes get built
in a matter of months,
but culture is built day by
day, over years and decades.
And I think it's really important
to take a long-term approach
to how we think about remote work.
- [Narrator] Mark Zuckerberg
here is discussing a problem
on the minds of many business leaders.
Research shows that when
employees leave places
with a high concentration
of specialized workers,
innovation is stifled.
And as the pandemic continues,
more companies are letting workers
move far away from the
office, sometimes permanently.
So why is proximity important,
and what are companies doing to adapt
to their decentralized workforces?
Over the decades,
tech companies like
Apple, Tesla and Facebook
opened offices in Silicon Valley,
creating a hub of
specialized tech workers.
Business leaders and economists
say that this proximity
is key to the success of a new venture.
Research from the labor
economist, Enrico Moretti
suggests that when specialized workers
live near one another,
their companies gain a
competitive advantage.
- Places like Silicon
Valley are very expensive
because labor costs more,
office space costs more,
but they also come with
a lot of advantages,
and especially if you are
in the innovation sector.
There's a growing body of research
that points to the fact that
firms and inventors and innovators
are particularly productive and creative
in places like Silicon Valley.
- [Narrator] In a recent paper,
Moretti traced the migration patterns
in patent filings of more
than 900,000 scientists,
inventors and engineers.
He found that when a worker leaves
an industry specialized city,
that worker innovates at a slower pace.
- In my data, I'm following
the same person over time.
I'm seeing an innovator
or inventor in rural Ohio,
in Cleveland, you know,
in this small place, in the small cluster,
and I see how many patents they create.
And then I see that person
moving to Silicon Valley
or Seattle or Boston.
And what you see is that the same person
becomes immediately
significantly more productive.
- [Narrator] Moretti says that on average,
a worker in a city with many
companies in their field
will produce better
ideas at a faster pace.
But during the pandemic,
people have left tech
clusters like San Francisco,
some permanently.
Companies say that some employees
want to be closer to their
home towns and families,
others are looking to save money.
Though the median price
for a one bedroom rental
fell in 2020,
San Francisco remains one of
the most expensive Metro areas
in the US.
Over recent years,
that led to a migration from the Bay
to places like Sacramento,
Las Vegas and Austin, Texas.
Companies have had to re-imagine
how they'll keep innovating
while their workforces spread out.
- When you try to measure
where innovation comes from,
it's hard to force it.
It's hard to tell people
we're gonna lock you in a room
and you're gonna be innovators.
- [Narrator] For a decade,
Laszlo Bock led people
operations at Google.
In 2017 he launched his own company, Hulu.
Hulu develops products that
influence worker behavior.
It's headquartered near Alphabet's
campus in Mountain View.
- In my prior job when I was at Alphabet,
we talked a lot about what
we called casual collisions
or moments of serendipity,
where people casually
bump into one another.
So famously Google News,
which is an aggregate of
websites evolved because
following the events of September 11th,
there were two engineers
standing in line at a cafe,
one of them was complaining about
how it's hard to keep up with all the news
and the other said I could
pull something together.
- [Narrator] Bock says that
these moments of serendipity
are the building blocks of innovation,
but they come most easily in person.
- Bringing people physically together,
and more importantly,
emotionally together is vital,
a prerequisite for innovation.
- [Narrator] Bock says that
innovation in the workplace
comes from low affinity distance.
- Affinity distance is central
to innovation and productivity.
It's that sense of
closeness, of connectivity,
of psychological safety,
that allows somebody to say,
I've got a crazy idea, I'm gonna try that.
And the challenge with remote work
is when you've been around people
and hung out with them and
talked about their kids
and had water cooler conversations,
you get low affinity distance,
we get closer to one another.
- [Narrator] Some companies prefer
to develop those bonds in person
and others are leaning
into the remote experience.
- There's a handful of
companies that are saying,
we're just gonna be remote forever,
we're gonna hire people
wherever they wanna be,
and that's how it's gonna be.
- [Narrator] In the short term,
companies are turning
to their own products
to build community.
Facebook, for example, is adding
workplace friendly features
to its portal video conferencing product.
- So we use our own
product, our nudge engine,
and it's great at finding
those little moments
where people can actually connect
and be human and innovate.
- [Narrator] Humu's nudge product
sends messages to
employees at specific times
to encourage behaviors
that boost productivity.
For example, it might
send a nudge that suggests
changing up weekly virtual
team bonding activities.
- By changing the prompt or
the type of event every month
or two or three months,
you refresh the experience
and you help bring people together.
- [Narrator] Other
companies are cutting down
on avoidable meetings
and designing workflows
that accommodate people who
live in different time zones.
- An example of this might be
having a really, really
clear problem statement
in a Google document and a
proposed solution to that,
and having multiple people
being able to weigh in
on that document, giving
comments on their own time,
and then that being sufficient enough
for the project leader to
synthesize all that information
and make the next iteration
of that proposed solution.
- [Narrator] Dominique Baillet
shapes the employee
experience at Coinbase,
a San Francisco tech company
that is now remote first.
She says, it's an opportunity
to make the workplace
more efficient for people
who may have otherwise been marginalized.
- Even before work environments
had been remote friendly before,
remote first creates more
equitable playing field
to root out some of the
systemic disadvantages
of not being in the office
when the majority of your
colleagues are in the office.
- [Narrator] At other
companies like Facebook,
corporate offsite gatherings
could invert into onsite
for remote workers at headquarters,
but alphabet, for example,
plans to have workers return
to the office when it's safe.
Surveys conducted by economists
say that after the pandemic,
about 25% of all full workdays
will be performed from home.
In the meantime,
companies will keep revamping
the remote experience.